salaam alaikum guys how you doing made a  pit stop here to make do here at the  masjid and we got some kids  and this is how the quran is is is  preserved  you know where anywhere you go no matter  what town  where you're at someone is reciting  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  is  [Music]  me  [Music]  is  [Music]  that amazing like no other book in the  world where you can just pull up as we  did in the village  and just random kids  in the village reciting the only book in  the world like the quran that's  memorized by millions all over and  that's how it's been intact since it was  revealed from the creator until this day  temper free tamper proof in its original  the quran and they were reciting it  and you heard that verse  say he is god the one and only the  absolute the eternal  he begets not nor is he begotten meaning  he's not the father of anyone nor  does he have  any children  and there's none comparable to him  amazing  assalamu alaikum